الى هذه النافذه من حي ابراهيم في مدينه
غازيه عنتاب احدى الولايات العشر المتضرره
من الزلزال ربما اكثر ما يلفت الانتباه
الان عدا عن هذه الصوره التي خلفه هي
الاهتزازات الارتداديه المتواتره اربع حتى
الان منذ الصباح مركزها كان في كهرمان
مرعش بطبيعه الحال مرتين
تقريبا اربع درجات الى ثلاثه وثمانيه من
العشره ايضا في ملاطيا كانت اربعه ودرجتين
من العشره ايضا هنا في منطقه اصلاحيه في
غازي عنتاب كانت تقريبا 54 من العشره على
مقياس اختار هذه اهتزازات ضمن الف اكثر من
1100 هزه ارتداديه بسبب الزلزالين
الكبيرين اللذين ضرب كهرمان مرعش تلاحظون
في صوره خلفيه هذا المبنى يبدو متضررا خرج
منه العشرات بسلام لكن للاسف هناك عدد من
المفقودين لنقل في الادوار السفليه لا
يعلم عددهم على التحديد بتقدير خمسه عشر
شخصا لكن توقفت عمليات الانتشال لخطوره
الموقع كما تلاحظون وهي من الصعوبات التي
تواجه فريق الانقاذ في هذه المنطقه ومناطق
عديده اذ ان المبنى لازال قائما على اصوله
وفي احيان كثيره لا يكون ممكنا الدخول
والاقتراب لانه قد يهدد حياه
العاملين في المنطقه من المنقذين سيتم
الان محاوله هد المبنى بشكل كامل بحيث
يكون امن لمحاوله الوصول الى ناجين سالت
العميل هنا هناك صوت هل تتوقعون
ان يكون هناك
ناجون لم يجبني قال لا نعلم هل هناك من
ناج اسفل هذا المبنى المدمر بطبيعه الحال
الرئيس التركي بعد ان اعلن التعبئه العامه
في هذه المناطق ارسل عدد من وزراء حكومته
لتولي كل منطقه على حده واسمعنا الى
تصريحات كثيره هذا اليوم تتعلق بمحاوله
اعاده الحياه الى طبيعتها في عدد من هذه
الولايات واعاده الخدمات